bon soit ment il est 21h dix policiers
et un sergent sont réunis dans la plus
grande discrétion au deuxième étage du
centre opérationnel sud ce sont tous des
volontaires
on les surnomme les braves pour barrages
routiers alcool au volant et évaluation
de stupéfiants in but d'intensifier les
barrages routiers rassurer les gens et
venez un peu démystifier le fameux m ce
n'est pas parce qu'on n'a pas la machine
encore détecté la drogue qu'on n'est pas
capable de détecter celui qui donne les
directives
c'est le lieutenant brian koning
l'architecte derrière cette nouvelle
escouade entré en service le 17 octobre
le jour même de la légalisation du
cannabis au canada l'an dernier pour le
louvre lens a pris le départ
convaincre les gens changent les
mentalités jour 1 de la légalisation on
agit mais ce soir le groupe planifie
trois barrages routiers à trois endroits
différents à vous consommez ce sont
leurs forces leur mobilité pour
surprendre les automobilistes
si l'effet du cannabis comme ici à
l'entrée du centre-ville de montréal à
la fermeture de magasins en moins de 30
minutes la circulation est au ralenti et
déjà des conducteurs doivent se
soumettre à l'épreuve de coordination
des mouvements en trois étapes d'abord
il ya le test du mouvement des yeux
l'effet du cannabis peut produire un
mouvement involontaire et saccadé du
globe oculaire puis il ya le test de la
démarche en vous demandera de marché sur
une ligne droite et de vous retourner et
il y a les tests de l' équilibre
on testera votre capacité à effectuer
plusieurs actions en même temps comme se
tenir sur un pied est compté à voix
haute jusqu'à 10 l'infraction conduite
avec capacité lui une infraction qui est
susceptible d'être mise par n'importe où
car on voit les victimes mortelles
d'accidents de blessés
je suis membre du mal qui blesse ou
équipe du mans qui se sont toujours et
karine et le nombre d'arrestations
autant aux pour capacités affaiblies par
la drogue sur l'île de montréal en 2015
112 arrestation 135 en 2016 et l'an
dernier 145 par les policiers de
montréal
à chaque fois les jeunes conducteurs des
18 à 24 ans étaient majoritairement en
cause sacrée un sacré mouchon c'est vrai
que ça peut aller jusqu'aux dents tant
fait qu'ils fassent des opérations
policières je pense que c'était une
crème d'un bon citoyen l'escouade brown
et qu'un projet pilote pour le moment
mais le responsable de la sécurité
routière au spvm y voir sa pertinence
fini le temps où est ce qu'on va faire
des barrages peut-être juste à l
approche de la période des fêtes où
quelque chose se passe le cannabis les
gens prennent malheureusement tout
moment
[Musique]
je sais écouter une histoire d'une
victime d'une famille qui a perdu
quelqu'un nous les mesures on peut seul
but et c'est encore parce qu'on y trouve
souvent dans sa phase de montage en
usine
les gens doivent comprendre le mot non
plus mon objectif sauver des vies avec
ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]